Well,
how are you? Cristian Cásseres greets you with
his brief news report on Kirchner in
Spanish. Two children are fighting for their lives
after an accident possibly caused
by a drunk driver. The incident
happened shortly after 8
p.m. on Thursday near
Ryan and Pecos streets.  According to the police of
our dates, the driver of a
Chevy salvage truck was traveling at a
high speed when it collided with
another truck where
minors aged 1 and 4 were traveling.
Five people were transported to the
hospital. The driver of the truck was
They stole he was arrested
and in another road accident a car
overturned and caught fire
on Friday morning this happened near the
tunnel that connects the airport
with the 215 freeway and hours later
another crash caused the closure of
wayne 1 boulevard and you lose  details of
these various incidents remain under
investigation
the teachers are having problems
with their health insurance  members of the heart county
school district board of trustees
met
thursday night to hear from the
teachers union they explained the problems
they are facing with their
health insurance provider tht health many
educators said doctors have
stopped seeing them due to  that the
insurance does not pay their bills and many
are being sent to
collection agencies and we continue to enjoy the
fall with temperatures more pleasant
than normal the smoke from the fires in
california continue to impact the valley
remember to take precaution if you have
respiratory problems the temperatures
will be in  the 90s and in the 80 degrees
for next week I'm Cristian
Cásseres with your previous
news now in Spanish good day
[Music]